Baban Oh welcome everyone to the floor
leave your memes on the reddit
nineteen-year-old so WI alright you know
the rules if your ceiling gank
unsubscribe already I don't want you i
completely disavow any one that's
ceiling game alright to all the ceiling
gang people alright here we go
who say I don't have a PP is this the
same big PP girl from be more get owned
yet flip an old ceiling game you just
got floor the line for real how do I do
that trick I need to do I need to know
how to this is the iPhone all right I
don't know even what what I knew it
I love wait 2017 LMS says he's back
through sleeping on the Tesla factory
floor Elin must floor gang confirmed
juice I knew it I knew it I knew it I
never doubted it it's me and Elin we've
always been consistent
now that floor gang is popping all these
all these people pretending oh no no you
have not stop pretending
alright you either is or you ain't int I
just want to thank peers because with
his videos I started learning English by
myself hey look at that and now able to
see his videos and study abroad coulda
had CS feelings from a Venezuelan
nineteen year old very nice big PP
that's cool hey never thought of a I
mean I was on my intention
but it if you benefited from it I'll
take it
Dilek steaks the creeper upstairs uh-huh
yes I did yes I did he sets it down on
the so-called floor where is this going
where he films his video that's right I
am on the floor as you can see no
pillows no nothing
even when I'm working answering emails I
sit here it's fine
hemorrhoids is not a problem if your ass
is steel
but we all know on second story floor is
actually a first story ceiling Felix can
delete this right now I am mod of this
Ehlinger something it all right moving
on he's already who I thought I
recognized it holy Sh shut up ah pews
already reacted to the coughing games
three years ago I bet I reacted to some
floor seal gangs that's funny was it the
same meme I got a check the first you
like you lose the og number one all
roads Erlanger longer came from the
floor that's right I almost shot you
sorry oh my god it lives so good oh my
god I left no Monty no damn red it made
me come back to this video
same bro same good good record though
that's a real I mean I wouldn't say no I
wouldn't ask but I wouldn't say no only
one business in the galaxy gets to you
this riche you just got a loan those
mom's man I know I said it wrong it was
a joke only one business in the galaxy I
can't believe they put that garbage in
that bill man egg you feel like I've
seen this I'll react to it again if I
have to the metal gear one is insane
dude I guess I have to grow the hair
back our way a God of War yeah god of
soil looks more like why do they always
make that face huh what's so acceso
there's nothing to be excited about ever
stop stop it what is it then soy I just
like
you know stop even though it has nothing
to do with me and doesn't affect me in a
single way current yo-yo World
Championship winner Gentry Gentry yeah
that's how you say his name stein
challenge piers to make advanced yoga
trick
that's impossible there's no way I could
do that
god dammit dude my yo-yo is downstairs
not that I am on the second floor or
anything I'm just saying there's a no I
need to stop doing that scream it's not
good for my throw what are those yo-yos
what are those yes I did say the mean
for real them
I'm so confused so first trick is called
the first step of the trick is to get
the yo-yo spinning and then once we
activate the door gang we gotta get the
yo-yo swinging a little back and forth
action if you know I'm saying remember
Felix it's all about the rhythm your
movement with a yo-yo swing yes yes my
Jody looks up to the floor alright
alright alright okay okay here it comes
I can't do it then do it improve flora
game I'll take your trip and I trick it
out one up here okay welcome here segars
have the night tonight the yo-yo
spinning our finger what to that now if
you're having trouble in wearing pants
that are way too tight like me one thing
that you can do is instead of throwing
the yo-yo in front of you like bodies do
today a little bit harder to catch in
your pocket what you can do is throw the
yo-yo so it's sideways in front of you
then when you go to launch it up you're
gonna have a much easier time catching
it I need I need a better Jojo this is
the problem I'll do this way I'm in the
camera yeah I'll do this again I'll
return once I got a better yo-yo instead
of this garbage that I got from was it
like that from the arcade alright some
fan art I made hoping this time it
doesn't get buried I knew it didn't what
are other sir I was like what are those
legs
goddamn the details on golly I clicked
on that that was like duck feet or
something
I leave the battle angel legs confirmed
it's very cool very cool big peepee huge
peepee oh my god Ricardo it might see
continue alright there's something else
happening in between
all right Australians what's your Excuse
huh no excuses
look at this man that's how it's done
that's how it's done
I did say good good well done you get
big peepee
dear Felix please remember who this cat
is remember that this is not what she
and remember that it's Katzman you found
him and named in this when you were
trying to find Sven at that one episode
if you try to hurt Katzman your ulcer oh
wow who posted this huh who posted this
fake I don't believe it I bet the cat
posted this floor getting rice up rice
up to where this either in hard because
this floor doesn't hurt to me babies
when they don't like that's a good mean
template sorry about the quality gross
I'll do another one why am I such an
epic soldier
Felix setup 2017 Felix setup 2020 it's
evolving just backwards I don't know I
don't need it
I'm happy on the floor I like it floor
gang for life blah
once you hit floor again you know it's
not worth day you know it's not worth
going back pizzas basement game what the
hell oh yeah yeah yeah that's how it is
look at the size of that thing my god
it's beautiful
tape that's right it's tape more
creative hypotheses I appreciate it keep
guessing you'll never guess it he'll
never the answer might shock you and
Linnet he doesn't forgive PewDiePie for
a colleague or a twitch thought oh no
how about a stuck-up [ __ ] bet she's
stealing gang he really neither got
banned recently we did a gamer's she
insists it was an O for that thing she
insists that it wasn't a man it was just
a suspension or you just had a cat there
le Nitti huh wait she named her cat Maya
that's illegal or people fighting but
were you happy did you have pudding this
is from the millionaire's video in case
you don't understand the context
we should leave the video right now if
you don't understand this mean cuz that
means you're from the ceiling how much
can I run this joke to the ground to the
floor ha what do we see what the mod CS
is bullsh inaccurate sorry guys this is
fake cannot confirm the end thank you
dude I gotta see this in all this glory
oh my god he has some amazing or she fan
are making this oh wait what the hell so
many no one ceiling gang wimpy dude it's
a sacrifice will they oh wait nevermind
wait what where am I Oh your ceiling
game show me the pee pee on your face
right now
Hey look Maya's here why are you here
are you stealing gang or floor game tell
me right now tell me right now what are
you doing do you want dude some amazing
fan art lately oh I love the art of
svenne that's so cool
PewDiePie when he's trying to sleep
after receiving line Linus computer you
may not the rest now there are monsters
nibbler
he's staring at me all the time it's so
creepy stop it
oh my god he's a creeper I said creepy
oh my god well you listen to the village
speech and they Loki making ellipses
might says shows Felix our island Felix
there it is oh that's right I forgot
dude I order tambourine maybe it arrived
hold the moment hold the moment
see lien gang
I mean Florrick I'm now about to play
the floor gang and gang it's a Swedish
song inspired by Sweden beautifu
veterans nine-year-olds this is so
wholesome okay metal 10% okay come on i
beat in the game just add a zero there
and we're good oh my god
it's there's so many different theories
so far no no one has gotten it right
yeah oh my god that's not yeah sir I
heard you guys like pouting anime girls
oh yeah well not me me when I see floor
gang I mean ceiling gang what is wrong
with my brain okay here it goes it goes
it's a bit scattered it's a bit scared I
don't know what ceiling gang is but I
was into it before it was cool say sack
right now
zigzag right now take that right up I
will bless you three times leanness
floor gang
okay that wasn't right how do I hold
this what I put it in this huh my thumb
it's too big it's not comfortable
all right oh my god it keeps going when
my fan art didn't make it until the why
but it reaches for 22 K outputs how did
I miss that then that's impossible
fake Felix bass now Felix place if I
read the PDF files I read them fish go
blub blub stop asking you're absolutely
useless and you're ugly I don't like you
you have no friends you will never have
any friends
oh yeah you got a problem with that just
a mad and he's still there and it will
freeze there forever because I will left
him there you stinky ugly thing ugly
thing like that should not be in lava
you should be alive and live and prosper
I didn't favor it keeps going you eat
plants plants grow on decomposed animal
bodies that's not Incan all right can we
not turn this into an anti vegan
subreddit please and they don't stop
keep going the girl with blue team's
said that she doesn't eat she does not
like buying absurd absurdly prized
things while she has 1k Jordans on I
don't need Oh see this is the thing all
I need is PewDiePie Murch threw the pie
headphones P D PI G feel floor and
tambourine there mama very can you
believe I got highest grade in music
damn that's louder than I thought
I don't realize how loud that was sorry
neighbors I was wearing the head I
didn't realize these are noise can't
they're not but there could be we came
we came to the other side kids is
officially boomer now see see okay since
we I read the previous is this I mean
there next one when I was a kid we
always joke that China was in the bottom
I'm confused now
it's Australia this makes no sense gives
misty his tips doing all the work around
the house trying to repair things he
can't wear my glasses dad jokes sitting
down on the floor because he is old what
that makes no sense
alright fine girl takes ten pesos out of
edge wallet head America Financial I'm
never gonna information recover this I'm
so mad I didn't make that joke myself
goddamnit well done well done big peepee
no floor you're always there for me so
supportive not like walls in staircases
always getting in the way see they get
it she gets it anyway I think you mean
neckflix adaptation vegans are weak
woman climbs much Everest approve vegans
are weak aren't weak dies okay that's
not vegan yeah
it isn't stop dying stop dying right now
prove you're vegan I'm stealing I'm
stealing gay smell like ass here is it
hey but better impossible
damn that actually looked kind of
comfortable maybe I'll try they if I'll
go to Australia
oh he he flicked the screen that's
hilarious okay great well done huge pipi
huge Australian pipi welcome all colors
all sexes all orientations all read the
religions all cultures all abilities all
ages all sizes except ceiling gang
except ceiling gang when will you learn
when will you learn it's enough to make
a grown man cry
he said it he said the thing welcome to
YouTube kid we've got you know masters
some Nautica kink no I'm sub nothing
I've been in the game five times already
and peels what is pewds do hees flow
game that's only this current are before
Oregon no no you cannot look he's crying
pisses floor-to-ceiling oh my god
there's more I know it's not nether
right that's the joke damn that kind of
was never I am such an they look the
same they look the flippin same it's so
annoying
oh my time go back please go back PDP
enemies throughout the years yeah the
anime continues it's gotten weirder over
the years but it's gotta keep going when
someone asks who the best editor in the
world is say hi right now
appreciate sigh of appreciating moment
[Music]
thank you side damn what stop
sympathizing with his little piece of
poopy wow that's an old photo that's in
Singapore you guys are nifty I'll give
you that I'll give you them disputes
think in English or Swedish this is how
I think this is what goes on inside my
brain are you scared you're not
tambourine gay hey peeps why do you
always wear that mask floor game Florian
table hasn't arrived yet let's keep this
going flogging all right uh no I'm
slowing up like I don't care I don't
need tables hoots fan out they never got
into the white oh these are all great
thank you that's a good idea I like that
when you spend months building Felix a
custom PC and he can't even say your
name malignus Lenny's name is Linus when
you create the floor gang and people
stop buying your chanting no you have
you still have to play the chair too
before again come on come on guys how ma
bees are not gonna pressure my MA or
guilt my audience into buying into my
products or my brand just to enjoy my
content
I'm not some twitch girl okay but yeah
buy the chair just buy the chair what's
wrong with you
after seeing your latest video I just
want you to know that there are some
Korean fans like me watching your videos
from Korea thank you ever watched
kdramas and they just go oh no I'm like
what is that word what does that mean I
need to know that way okay so I'm not
the only one so no luck sorry
okay he's getting ready to fight the
Ricardo that's right ever since I went
floor gang big monsters just get bigger
automatically don't even need to lift
subscribe and become floor gang right
now your pee pee will increase so will
your muscle at least 10 percent Felix
when he gets his new desk floor gang I
don't want to play with it it's never
gonna happen
thank you for watching this video if you
enjoyed hit the like button gently
emerge and I see you guys tomorrow in a
world where science knows no boundaries
travel to land where no tuber has been
that Bloor never-before-seen landscapes
encounter beings that are extinct meet
Mayan actors ancestors who collect
ancient items rediscover your favorite
scientifically accurate dinos what will
you create
you